i'm very blessed and i don't know what
the future looks like so i'm not going
to predict it shoot i i couldn't try it
any harder you know i had a chance to
talk to cam yesterday and i have the
utmost respect for for him and what he's
done we can win with this one we can win
we can definitely win with another one
too because we're going to have a
defense
if if if i'm back and and taysom's there
alongside me
call the plays that are going to put us
in the best position to win right if
that means taysom hill is taking 30
snaps a game
25 snaps a game then so be it it's to be
better like signing a new contract or
not having to answer questions about
getting a new contract which will
actually be better that's tough yeah
probably signing yeah i think so
a lot of uncertainty in this offseason
and things can go a bunch of different
ways i will say this so i was reminded
hearing matt rule talk about cam newton
anytime someone says utmost respect it's
over it's done that's the precursor to
we're going in a different direction i
have the utmost respect for you big cat
but uh we've decided to end this
relationship so i i don't want to tip my
my predictions but i have a feeling that
matt rule would like to move on from cam
newton and then cam newton maybe would
like to move on from the panthers all
right
this draft
off-season predictions and god only
knows what direction this is going to go
especially when the mind of big cat
begins to come up with all sorts of
ideas trivia question for the first pick
jay cutler is the bear's career leader
in passing yards and touchdown but he
doesn't hold the single season record
for either of those categories which
bears quarterback has the single season
record for touchdown passes and passing
yards i just assume it's sid luckman
because he's second in all of the
categories
[Music]
my god i'm astounded for two reasons two
reasons first you don't know you're
bears it's eric kramer
right there that yeah okay that makes
sense but i i i just say sid luckman
because he's number two on everything
besides jay cutler
but would it be better to actually know
the facts than assume it's sid luckman
secondly this is stupid we used the
exact same question yesterday you don't
watch the show
so you can never bust my chops about not
listening to pardon my take we agree on
that i don't listen to pardon my take
and you don't watch the show on the days
that you're not on the show i don't i
definitely don't watch the show you're
absolutely right i definitely don't
watch the show that was never in doubt
all right here's my prediction and we
have to be clear that these are
predictions i saw that espn.com had a
bit where every one of their beat
writers had a prediction for the
off-season and some turned that into a
report of what's gonna happen this isn't
a report this is a prediction prediction
number one for me tom brady is leaving
the new england patriots that's my
prediction because i believe the only
way he stays is if bill belichick gets
on a knee and professes his undying love
for tom brady applies his lips to each
butt cheek of tom brady and pays him
more than 30 million dollars belichick
isn't gonna do it brady's gonna leave
that's my prediction
i couldn't disagree with you
more you think he's still wrong you're
wrong all right i think he's staying
here i think it's going to be
one of those
yeah sure whatever you want to bet i i
think you owe me about your jackpot
right now how about no about your jacket
i think it's going to be one of those
situations where we will hear uh when is
free agency start march 14th is that
right 18th
18th we will hear
somewhere around march 1516 that tom
brady bill belichick and robert kraft
all had a dinner together that lasted
seven hours and there were tears and
there was wine no strawberries but maybe
a little steak and they hashed it all
out and they said let's get the band
back together and let's give this
another run for two more years that's
what's going on i think if that happens
i think that happens it's happening
before march 15. by march 15 the ship
has sailed i think if it's going to
happen it's going to happen within the
next few weeks and there's enough out
there there's enough already out there
with brady deliberately trolling and and
i think brady likes the attention i mean
he set himself up to have a shot at free
agency at this stage of his career i
think he's reached his lifetime limit of
dealing with bill belichick 20 years is
more than enough and i think he's ready
to move on unless bill belichick shows
that he is willing to change the way he
interacts with the way he regards the
way he treats brady he's always been
able to keep brady down a little bit and
one of the reasons i think brady has
taken less over the years i think
brady's taken less not because he wants
to have more money for other players i
think he's never wanted to get cut by
belichick because belichick looks at
what brady's doing looks at how much
he's paying him and decides i'm paying
this guy too much money i think that's
one of the reasons why brady's always
done it so i think brady is ready to get
out from under this this this this cloud
that he has resided under for 20 years
and i think he's leaving what's your
first who who's keeping you down it
feels like that was projecting that felt
oddly personal there when you're like i
just he just wants respect and he wants
people to realize it's him
oddly personal who's keeping you down
just ask yourself that later tonight
someone is do you have do you have them
do you have the monitor do you have the
monitor on can you see the monitor the
guy on the right side of the screen is
who i'm talking about is that
you got what he's saying okay uh all
right so i'm belichick that's fine my
first pick which you are going to
disagree with very much so
uh cam newton will stay on the carolina
panthers i disagree a lot of panthers
yeah i know i know you disagree they're
gonna look around and they're gonna say
where's the what's the better option
here where is it you know what i kind of
let's see what we have with cam newton
one more year if he's healthy he still
can be a top 10 guy you don't walk away
from guys like that
do it for one more year next year you
can make the decision based on how he
plays this year i think they're gonna
have a come to jesus moment and realize
hey there's not a lot of options out
there right now for quarterback maybe
draft someone they drafted will grier
last year get him working a little bit
more cam newton will still be on the
panthers come week one
how can you say there's not a lot of
options at quarterback have you seen all
the names in free agency all the guys
who are available who aren't free
phillip rivers what about philippines
better cam newton's better
if he's healthy i think the organization
has reached a level of fatigue with this
constant concern is he healthy can he
get healthy will he be healthy and look
only the team knows what it's like to
deal with cam newton behind the scenes
they've done a good job of never having
any public explosions but remember the
video last year with the cigar and the
glass of cabernet and he kind of bared
his soul about the injury i i don't
think they like that and there's a lot
of change happening now new owner new
coach there's a new vibe and when david
tepper was asked about cam newton and he
said it's important we have guys here
who buy in
that tells me that pepper maybe thinks
newton doesn't buy in and and tepper's
had a year to monitor newton i think
they're going to move on and it's a very
tradable contract and i think he's going
to get traded to the chargers that's
where i think he's going to be in 2020.
all right we disagree
next one for me next one for me drew
brees is returning to the saints in
2020. i believe that based on on
interviewing him last week what i
thought
he's seriously considering retirement i
think he's going to think so
i don't know
no i think he's going to play i don't
think he's seriously considering
retirement i think that drew brees
definitely wants to play and he's gonna
stay and do another year and look where
that team has been every single year the
last three years they've been in the
playoffs they've had a chance i mean you
could say obviously they lost the first
round this year but it feels like
they've had a chance to win the super
bowl every year in terms of looking at
the landscape and they're one of the
best five teams but you know by the late
december so i think he's going to come
back and say we still have a chance
let's try to do this again
i i think that he is seriously
considering retirement i was told that
that the team is actually trying to talk
him into coming back uh they want to
move on to take some hell at some point
but not this year and i think the
contemplations are more serious this
isn't a brett favre look at me ben
roethlisberger look at me move we've
never heard this from brees in all these
years and he told us last week he
seriously considered retiring after the
2017 season going into that year if they
hadn't had that turnaround that they had
he may have walked away then and no one
ever said boo about it this isn't drew's
way to try to conjure fake attention by
suggesting that he's considering
retirement just so people talk about it
i think he's seriously considering it
and i think he's coming back what do you
got next okay my next one's very bold i
thought these were bold predictions i
didn't realize they were mike florio
just
stating the obvious uh but my bold
prediction
here well cam cam newton standing on the
panthers is really going out on a limb
that is absolutely a bold prediction you
said there's basically no chance he
stays
uh
my next prediction
off-season prediction
jameis winston i don't know how the
money is going to work out we'll figure
that out some other time
jameis winston will be signed by the
chicago bears and i'm ready for it oh
one oh
future hall of famer jameis winston on
the chicago bears let's do it let's do
it i'm ready do you my body do you want
him do you want him to bears yeah why
not let's have fun
let's get crazy
what happens to
mitchell t
uh
we'll figure it out maybe he you keep
them both
yeah we'll we'll run like uh the lloyd
carr offense at michigan we'll go
quarters
first quarter
mitch second quarter jameis
that is bold i i don't think the
buccaneers are going to let him go i
think they're trying to wear him down
and maybe soften his expectations 50 109
passing yards eighth all-time single
season mark you got to keep him if
you're the buccaneers you got to keep
jameis winston but i just wanted a bold
prediction i want to put the side
ether yeah
yeah okay thank you and it's going to
get attached to me somehow and i'm going
to get blamed for the whole thing last
one for me and i'm going to keep it i'm
going to keep it quasi serious or mostly
serious i think the raiders are moving
on from derek carr i think they're going
to upgrade at the quarterback position
and car will not be with the team in
2020. so that house that he built next
door to john gruden he's never going to
actually live in it he's going to sell
it to whoever the quarterback of the
raiders is in 2020. i think derek carr
is just awkward enough to maybe still
live in it maybe that's his offseason
and he's just like i'm just hanging out
here that actually would be a great move
wouldn't it just because like you know
it would bother gruden if you just live
next to him in the off season after
after gruden cuts them i agree with this
i think i could see this happening so uh
good pick mike my last pick is the best
pick in the draft
with the cba negotiations going
negotiations going on when when is that
going to ramp up mike when is the cba
negotiation it is right now it is okay
they're gonna get it done by march 18th
or it gets tabled for a year i think
all right so then i i'll phrase it this
way mike florio will continue to get
into arguments online about the cba
negotiations and what is happening uh
with the league and the players
that's really going out on a limb boy
you've really gone out on a limb there
you're really putting your reputation on
the line with that one you're gonna you
this is
mike floria if you don't have alerts on
for his tweets once these negotiations
ramp up mike florio the lawyer comes out
and that's a bulldog you don't want that
never lost the case never lost the case
actually you know what i'm not going to
disagree with you even though you're
wrong uh you did lose the kids
and anybody anybody who's never lost a
case has never tried a case because
there's so much uncertainty that goes
into it you can never control what six
or twelve people are going to do so uh
yes i i i do i i will say this
um it does irritate me because so many
of the people who follow the sport have
no clue how this all works and they just
spit out whatever someone tells them
without any context or analysis so
you're probably right i will be fighting
not that i fought with anyone recently
or like in the last 12 hours or or will
do soon as soon as the show's over and i
go and see whether or not a a a tweet a
certain tweet that is a bold-faced lie
has been deleted or revised no other
than that there'll be no fighting for me
i i do appreciate in all seriousness
mike will throw aside you know the fun
we're having here i do appreciate your
point of view when it comes to these
type of things because as a regular fan
i don't understand any of it and when it
comes to like the legalities the
contract negotiations none of this makes
sense to me so mike florio is your
source never lost a case let's just put
that as a tagline mike florio never lost
the case never lost a case you didn't
want to lose how about that um
probably
no that won't work either never lost a
case of malt liquor
uh never lost a case of uh football
cards uh i mean depending upon what the
case is then i think we can make that
into a true statement
you never lost the case you won there it
is
you literally have never lost in case
you won yeah that would if i would have
ever done those those uh lawyer
advertisements that i never really
wanted to do because i couldn't bring
myself to do it that would have been the
great tag line i've never lost a case i
won um all right let's take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports